ja das thema was ich ihn mitbringen ist
geplante ob so les sens klingt wie der
krankheit ist auch eine ja also die
geplante obsolescence was ist damit
gemeint
ich würde heute behaupten 80 prozent der
konsumgüter sind so gebaut dass sie
kürzer halten obwohl sie unter sonst
gleichen bedingungen zu sonst gleichen
kosten mit dreifacher haltbarkeit hätten
gebaut werden können dieses thema
diskutieren wir von unserem verein murks
nein danke ev jetzt schon seit 2012 als
wir damit angefangen haben wurde gesagt
dass es eine verschwörungstheorie heute
haben wir mittlerweile steht jetzt auch
schon in der eu mit drin also geplante
ob soll des sands ist als problemfeld
erkannt allerdings passiert viel zu
wenig und das ist natürlich etwas wo wir
genauso zu packen müssen wie den anderen
bereichen und eine geplante ob solutions
des whatsapp so lässt
sind geplante sollbruchstellen ein keine
sollbruchstellen sollbruchstellen sind
etwas gutes da würde ja würde sagen die
warte mal eine sollbruchstelle ist etwas
das soll brechen damit etwas schlimmeres
nicht passieren es sind schwachstellen
es sind aber auch manchmal so dinge wenn
sie zum beispiel sagen mein kühlschrank
ist kaputt und dann rufen sie
meinetwegen bei media markt an und dann
sagen die vielleicht ja das dauert seit
sechs wochen müssen wir einen schicken
was soll man da sagen viele dass bei mir
wieder zu hause ankommt kauf ich mir
doch lieber gleich nein es ist hat
wieder geklappt eigentlich leicht gesagt
wie man wie mich denn nicht über die
technik verfügt das gerät hat nur eine
gewisse haltbarkeit damit extra kaputt
geht ja da werden richtig sogar ich gebe
ihnen ein beispiel ein krebs handmixer
da hatten den hat man auseinander ist
kaputt gegangen haben wir den
auseinander gebaut worden in der
werkstatt da ist den zahnräder drin
grundstoff zahnräder muss kunststoff
sein weil sonst stromschlag
geräuschentwicklung täter war und das
sind schneckengetriebe drin das hat da
richtig eine spur eingefräst und im
dritten jahr der nutzung sind die kaputt
gegangen diese zahnräder habe ich nach
langer recherche sogar als ersatzteil
gefunden vier euro 50 hätten sie nur
gekostet aber ohne jede not sind die in
dem handmixer somit metallplatten fest
verbaut gewesen dh man kann jetzt dieses
verschleißteil überhaupt nicht tauschen
und das ist eine von vielen methoden wie
dann bei herstellern anders gemacht wird
das eben etwas sozusagen nach einer
bestimmten nutzungsdauer kaputtgeht
essen zähler nachgewiesen worden drucker
und jetzt ist ja gerade apps und wieder
groß in der diskussion apple ist
mittlerweile in italien verurteilt
worden wegen geplanter ob solist enz in
frankreich gibt es gesetze gegen
geplante ob soll ist es also woanders
ist man da schon zu gange ja nur in
deutschland passiert noch zu wenig frau
blank sie ist der elektrotechnik können
sie das bestätigen sie am definitiv mehr
wissen als ich also es gibt auf jeden
fall immer teile die kaputt gehen können
zum beispiel die ganzen kondensatoren
die gehen immer recht schnell kaputt
haben dann kann das einfach sein das
gerät einmal aufmachen musste dagegen
ein kondensator jeweils auslöst und dann
den neuen kondensator wieder einlösen
also sowas kann eben auf jeden fall
passieren und java 7 brüchigkeit bei
plastik ja kommt natürlich genauso vor
haben ist es halt immer wichtig dass das
gerät gut öffnen kann das tat schrauben
gibt weil wenn man das gerät hat
aufbrechen muss dann das hat natürlich
automatisch schon kaputt ein sehr schöne
sehr schönes beispiel zb die senseo
kaffeemaschine die hat unten drin auch
so eine platine nicht die muss ja
arbeiten und da geht dann auch so ein
kondensator kaputt und da würde der
elektrotechnik hat sich jetzt sagen
manche wunderbaren kondensator auslösen
einen blöden das kriegen wir auch noch
hin das gilt auch gleich aber man muss
die maschine kaputt machen sie ist also
verklebt unten das heißt keine schrauben
das heißt man muss sozusagen die clips
wegbrechen aufbrechen damit man
überhaupt dran kommt um es zu reparieren
und ohne jede not haben das nach
kalkuliert mit schrauben das zu machen
wäre genauso teuer wie diese
klubgeschichte also es ist jetzt keine
kosten entscheidung gewesen schritte
hier hier ist hab ich die frage ich habe
noch gefragt wenn ich jetzt
unternehmerin wäre für waschmaschinen da
wir schon mal wissen getestet habe ich
wenn ich so erfolgreich aber sagen wir
mal ich wäre jetzt technisch
unternehmerin da würde ich doch
probieren das beste produkt zu erstellen
damit noch die mutter später zum tochter
sagt die waschmaschine kauft so aber bei
zink ja also warum macht man extra
schlechtere produkte die er dann auch
nicht weiter empfohlen werden die
kriegen denn heutzutage in der zeit des
internets schlechte kritiken also
eigentlich ist es doch man weiß sich
doch selber eigentlich in den eigenen
schwanz rein tatsächlich nicht
nehmen wir mal ein da hat man schöne
sendung mit mit einem philips
staubsauger 99 euro
und der ist auch kaputt gegangen und der
hat dann en d'r in dem muss man richtig
auf flexen den motor und da waren drin
der sauger ist ein ventilator der die
substanz auch mit also so jämmerlich
schlecht gebaut das ist schon sehr
aufwendig war okay jetzt fragt man sich
was soll das
naja jetzt ist halt die geschichte nicht
sie kaufen sich hat den staubsauger
sondern sie gehen im laden ihrer wahl
reinsehen dort den staubsauger das heißt
der handel stellt diesen staubsauger
inside regalreihen und ich würde mal
behaupten der handel bestellt geplante
ob solist enz er bestellt das jetzt
nicht in der form dass er sagt macht uns
damals schlechten ventilator ein sondern
er bestellte ihn in der form dass er
sagt leute baut uns bitte staubsauger
die wir alle drei jahre neu verkaufen
können mode wechselt ist ja auch so was
ja wir können heute mode wechsel alle
sechs wochen ja die songs in der mode
der handel findet die pro betrieb sind
wir kennen das von unserer seite her als
das time-to-market problem und da gibt
es den wettbewerb jeder die unternehmen
wollen gerne
hochpreisige regen jetzt ich will sie
keine werbung bei waschmaschinen zum
beispiel wird schon ja manchmal von
generation zu generation noch ein
gewisser waschmaschine oder
weitergegeben ja den kauft man ja weil
man die qualität will aber der macht das
auch mit schwachstelle also es gibt auch
hoch preise das produkt das interessante
ich gebe ein beispiel es gibt zb von
siemens eine waschmaschine die unter
demselben namen verkauft wird und dort
hatte jemand den kundendienst menschen
zu sich gerufen und gesagt kommen sie
mal was kaputt machen sie mal heile und
dann hat er ihm das heilige macht geht
leider nicht mag hat er so im nebensatz
gesagt sie müssen sich auch eine
richtige siemens kaufen und da hat er
uns auf etwas aufmerksam gemacht die
mich es gibt das gleiche modell einmal
als made in romania und einer made in
germany und dann sind das so detail
unterschiede also wie bei zahnrädern zb
die stoßdämpfer diesen unten aufgehängt
mit kunststoff und dann ist manchmal da
wo der stoßdämpfer sozusagen so gegen
zieht metall mit bei damit der druck
nicht aus kunststoff geht und manchmal
ist das metall halt weg und dann geht
der druck immer aus kunststoff drauf und
dann bricht das natürlich irgendwann
solche kleinen unterschiede sind das und
wie kommt das naja weil mediamarkt zum
beispiel dann sagt mir auch ein
massenprodukt da zahlen wir euch nicht
viel im einkauf man kriegt ja das mit
konsument kann man wie wachsam bleiben
internet checken kritiken lesen ja die
einfachste methode ist eigentlich also
wenn man jetzt ins regal rein greift
sind gibt es zwei fragen die man dem
verkäufer immer stellen sollte die erste
ist sagen wir mal wie lange hält das und
die zweite frage ist kriege ich auch in
der ganzen zeit ersatzteile und das
schon dicke backen das ist auch gut da
haben den richtig praktikabel
lösungsvorschlag wie man als konsument
in der zukunft elektro tal und anderes
kaufte ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
abend wir sind nächste woche dienstag
wieder für sie da herzlichen dank an
meine gäste tschüss bis bald